you know I've I've often been told by
viewers and listeners that my show is
not as classy and not as professional as
the other shows on the daily wire
because I'm always doing it in my car or
like in my house you know in fact I've
been told that my show isn't even really
a show because I don't have the nice
background and the fancy setup with all
the nice whatever the desk and the
lights and all that kind of the makeup
artists okay special effects I don't
have any of that stuff I've been
listening to those criticisms and I've
decided to finally solve that problem
and so what I did is I I went out and I
got a globe you see this globe right
here I don't mean to brag about my globe
everyone knows that when you add a globe
into a setting it ups the classiness
quotient and the professionalism
quotient by quite a bit in fact there
was even a study done recently I think
that that demonstrated there's there's a
direct correlation between your IQ and
how many Globes you have in your home I
have three Globes just in this room
right here I don't mean to brag about my
gloves but you know let me ask you this
yeah the other shows on The Daily wire
they're very professional looking how
many Globes do they have do they have
any Globes I rest my case now we talked
last week about the immigration debate
and I gave my opinion which is very
simply that our laws should be enforced
and that the border should be protected
I don't like to see kids separated from
their families and I certainly don't
like to see the kind of abuse that has
happened in some situations to these
kids starting under the Obama
administration but the law has to be
enforced certainly which means stopping
these families detaining them preferably
detaining them together so they're not
being separated and then sending them
back to their rightful legal homes now I
received an angry email after that show
and it is a show especially not with the
globe after that show on Friday I
received an 8 well I received several
angry emails as per usual but this one a
particular gave voice to a to a common
objection and this person said that my
position and the position of any any
advocate for immigration enforcement
that position lacks compassion and we
need to have compassion for illegal
immigrants
it's important to be compassionate the
government has to be compassionate we
need we need to have compassionate laws
and to be compassionate to these people
compassion is I'm sure you've noticed
one of the most overused misused abused
words in the English language so I want
to talk about compassion and I think we
should begin by defining compassion and
so I went to
went to the dictionary to do that but
before we get to the definite to the
definition here's my here's my basic
position on compassion I don't want the
government
be compassionate towards illegal
immigrants
I don't want compassionate laws
I don't want compassionate policies I
don't want a compassionate government
doing compassionate things and the word
compassionate and all those previous
sentences
just imagine the the scare quotes around
it I think that any any law or policy or
government action that's justified on
the basis of compassion like say welfare
for instance is always in the end a bad
thing and it's always in the end
something that does more harm than good
so no I don't want compassion when
someone says well don't want you don't
want the government to be compassionate
towards illegals no actually I don't
I think compassion is great compassion
is not just great it's it's necessary it
is required
but I don't want the government to be
compassionate I don't think the
government can be compassionate so now
we'll look at the definition of
compassion
compassionate this.what compassionate
means compassionate means sympathetic
consciousness of another person's
distress together with a desire to
alleviate it so when you're
compassionate you're sympathetic you're
you you you have a consciousness of
their suffering and you want to
alleviate now compassion comes from the
Latin it's if you follow its etymology
it comes from Latin and from an
etymology perspective it means Co
suffering okay so it's related to
empathy when you have compassion for
someone it means that you're suffering
with them that you're you're feeling
what they feel you feel as they feel and
then if it's refits real compassion if
it's useful compassion then you're
acting on that feeling but
you you notice something about this
definition
it is an intensely personal thing
you know a person is compassionate
towards another person
and what I would submit is that only a
person can be compassionate towards
another person
an institution
cannot be compassionate because an
institution doesn't feel anything a law
cannot be compassionate because a law
does not feel
passion is in action but it's also a
feeling it starts with a though or or a
consciousness at least but laws and
institutions can't do that now as I said
last week the government should act
according to a moral standard and laws
should be written and enforced by a
moral standard because moral is a is a
is a matter of objective right and wrong
and the government should emphasis on
should do the right thing so when I say
the government should act morally what
I'm saying is the government should do
the right thing and not the wrong thing
even though a lot of times if government
does the wrong thing and laws laws
should be should be right in the sense
that a law should be written according
to this moral standard and a law should
never prohibit anything that's good
and laws should only prohibit things
that are bad which isn't to say that the
that the law should prohibit everything
that's bad is just to say that
everything that is prohibited should be
bad
everything that's bad should be
prohibited so but none of this I'm
getting off into the weeds now none of
this has anything to do with compassion
which again is personal morality is an
objective standard against which all
people laws institutions can and should
be judged but compassion is a personal
feeling a personal conviction which
motivates an individual but laws and
institutions and policies should be
concerned with feelings and convictions
they should only be concerned with
what's right and wrong and it is right
to have a border and it is right to have
laws concerning its citizenship and
immigration not only right but necessary
and because it's necessary it is then
right you know in other words I it's
it's it's in order to have a country
it's necessary to have these laws so
therefore it's the government's job to
come up with those laws and enforce them
but feelings don't factor in and they
shouldn't and they can't because the
government doesn't feel the government
is not a feeling institution to can't
feelings are not collective things that
you do together there's something that
you do individually and you see I think
this is this is a big part of the of the
story of liberalism in in modern times
you know the left what the left has done
is they've tried to pawn compassion and
sympathy and generosity you know and
charity and all these things they've
tried to take all of that and remove it
from the individual and give it to the
government the individual leftist wants
to relieve himself of the burden of
being compassionate personally and
empathetic personally and generous
personally and charitable personally and
so he creates in his mind this idea of
the state as this kind of benevolent
organism which can which which can take
on the job of being virtuous so that the
rest of us don't have to be so the left
the left sees the state as almost this
kind of perverse backwards Christ figure
you know whereas Christ took on the
burden of mankind sinned and suffered
for our sins so that we don't have to
the state in the mind of the left takes
on mankind's virtue and acts virtuously
so that we don't have to and so it's a
really weird thing that they've done and
so that means you know that explains if
you're you know if you believe in
enforcing immigration law or if you
advocate for getting rid of the welfare
state or something a liberal will say to
you well where is your compassion where
is your generosity you don't have any
compassion and the reason why they
respond that way is because they see no
distinction between the state and the
individual and therefore they see no
distinction between the virtue of the
individual and the virtue of the state
and therefore if we take these virtuous
acts away from the state then in the
mind of a leftist we have taken them
away from the individual it seems like
they really don't understand that I
could make the case and I do make the
case for getting rid of entitlements yet
I strongly believe on an individual
basis that we as individuals are are
called
to to help the less fortunate and we
should do that
so I want
what I want to do is I want to take that
away from the state and give it to the
individuals but the left if you talk to
a leftist he doesn't think that's
possible
the state cannot be virtuous
it can't be empathetic it can't be
compassionate it can only use those
concepts which are which are personal
concept and it can only use them as a
cover to gain more power and control for
itself which is what the state has done
which is why I say we need to turn the
picture back around and restore things
to their proper order so let the
individual be generous let the
individual be compassionate let the
individual be virtuous absolutely if
you're concerned with the for the poor
and you should be concerned for them
then go and care for them go out into
the street right now
okay turn this stupid video off and go
out into the street if you're leaving a
comment right now say oh this is wrong
where's your okay then turn the video
off shut your computer go out into the
street right now find a homeless person
find a poor person take them out to
lunch give them some of your money take
take take $40 out of your wallet and
just give it to them or go buy them a
bag of groceries I mean dude go
volunteer at a soup kitchen okay that's
what you should do that's what we all
should do you can go out and give your
own money and your own time and your own
resources to the poor you should do that
that's compassionate it is your job
individually to be and act
compassionately the government can't do
it for you you have to do it
stop looking for the state to be
compassionate in your place go and do it
yourself
and if you're concerned for immigrants
and you should be concerned for them
then there are many ways to help them
there are many ways to serve the less
fortunate in foreign countries you could
donate to them you can find a great
charity give them your money you can you
can give them your time your resources
you can even go down to Central America
go to Mexico serve the poor there and
you could do all these things and be
compassionate towards them and you
should be but that's your job it's not
the government's job the government's
job is to enforce the law and to enforce
the law justly and to enforce laws that
are moral and the law that says you have
to be a citizen to live here that is a
moral law a moral law in the sense that
it is a it is a it is a law that's
perfectly in keeping with moral
standards you see the left really has it
backwards and more with more ways than
one because you know a leftist will say
that the law and the government should
be compassionate and empathetic
ascribing these kinds of human qualities
to institutions but then a leftist will
also say that we can't legislate
morality and morality is not the
government's concern so what the left is
done is they've turned morality into
this completely subjective personal
emotional thing and then they've taken
compassion and sympathy and turn them
into impersonal objective bureaucratic
things so once again that they've turned
everything just it's completely
backwards
the moral law is objective like gravity
is objective and any human institution
is subject to it but compassionate
compassion can only be practiced by the
individual not by the government it's
compassion that is a that is a personal
thing an emotional thing
it's not for the government
we have to stop looking to the
government to operate based on emotional
convictions
the government can't do that and it's a
really really bad idea to ask it to
the government should be concerned with
enforcing the law
and then we as individuals
we could come around and be compassion
so another example somebody breaks
thought someone a United States citizen
breaks the law commits a felony you know
is kill somebody robs a bank whatever
and well what the government should do
we're not looking for the government or
the law to have any feelings towards
that person the government's job is to
enforce the law enforce it fairly
enforce it justly which is going to mean
putting them in prison and then we as
individuals we can go visit that if
you're concerned with that person and
you want that person to feel compassion
well then you as an individual you can
go to the prison and visit that person
and minister to them and care for their
family and there's so much that you can
do for them
government did its job putting this
person in prison forcing the law now
it's up to you to be compassionate and
emotional and sympathetic and generous
and charitable that's on you
so I guess the answer to the question
when somebody says where is your
compassion
well my compassion is uh it's it's in
here oh it's it's it's it's inside
myself it's not out there it's not it's
not what the government it's it's within
me
and it's up to me to act on not to ask
the government to act on it
all right
yeah I think I think the globe really
improved that whole discussion don't you
I feel like it did thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening I'll talk
to you tomorrow